in the really old days people had to
write their code directly to work on the
hardware they Rock load and store
instructions to get stuff in and out of
memory and they played about with bits
and bytes and stuff you could do pretty
good work with that but it was very
specialized then they figured out that
you could build languages fit for humans
for specific areas like they built
Fortran for engineers and sciences and
they built COBOL for for businessmen and
then in the mid 60s a bunch of
Norwegians mostly over you are down
Christ Moog or thought why can't you get
a language that sort of is fit for
humans for all domains not just linear
algebra and business and they built
something called Simula and that's where
they introduced the class is the thing
you have in the programs represent a
concept in in your application world so
if you're a mathematician the matrix
will become a class if you're a
businessman a personnel record might
become a class in telecommunications a
dial buffer might become a class you can
represent just about anything as a class
and they went a little bit further and
represented relationships between
classes any hierarchical relationship
could be done as a bunch of classes so
you could say that a fire-engine is a
kind of a truck which is a kind of a car
which is a kind of a vehicle and
organize things like that this became
known as object-oriented programming
also in some variants of it as data
abstraction and and my idea was very
simple to take the ideas from simular
for general abstraction for the for the
benefit of sort of humans representing
things so humans could get it with the
low-level stuff which at that time was
the best language for that was C which
was done at Bell Labs by by Dennis
Ritchie and take those two ideas and
bring them together so that you could do
high
abstraction but efficiently enough and
close enough to the hardware for for
really demanding computing tasks and
that was where I came in
and so C++ has classes like similar but
they run as fast as C code
so the combination becomes very useful
yeah I say if I have to characterize
c-plus prices strength it comes from the
ability to have abstractions and have
them so efficient that you can can
afford it in infrastructure and you can
access hardware directly as you often
have to do with operating systems with
real-time control little things like
cell phones and so the combination is
gives something that is good for for
infrastructure in general another aspect
that's necessary for infrastructure is
stability when you build an
infrastructure it could be sort of the
lowest level of IBM mainframes talking
to the hardware for the higher level of
software which is a place the you C++ or
a fuel injector for a large marine
diesel engine or or a browser it has to
be stable for decade or so because you
can't afford to fiddle with the stuff
all the time you can't afford to rewrite
it I mean taking one of those ships into
hub or cost a lot of money and so you
need a language that not just good at
what it's doing you have to be able to
rely on it being available for decades
on a variety of different hardware and
to be used by programmers or a decade or
two at least C++ is now about three
decades old and if that's not the case
you have to rewrite your code all the
time and that happens primarily with
experimental languages and with
proprietary commercial languages that
change to to finish fast so to meet fads
C++ is problem is the complexity partly
because we haven't been able to clean it
up there's still code written in the 80s
that are running and people don't like
they're running codes to break
it could cost them millions or more